[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
carl hagler nicked out and garnered
hathaway they combined for two goals
three assists
simultaneously rooney and dowd
d giuseppe going at it with hathaway
blackwell and haglin
one second in that's how it started last
night
nbcsn nhl and nbc inside the glass
analyst pierre maguire
was on the call for that game last night
he'll be on the call for tonight's
rangers bruins match up
nbcsn probably less fireworks
in that one and uh pierre kind enough to
join us pierre when did you sense that
there was something that was going to
happen
prior to or quickly after the puck was
dropped
uh probably earlier in the afternoon dan
when i had a chance to talk to lars
eller of the washington capitals the
washington capitals clearly brought
their
a game not just athletically but
physically as well and
i think they were tired of some of the
rhetoric that was going out there about
their team i know the rangers were very
tired about some of the rhetoric that
was going on around their team so i
think earlier in the afternoon i kind of
felt there was going to be
some shenanigans that were going to
happen whether it happened at the start
of the game or the middle of the period
i didn't know
but also if you send the fourth line out
both teams
i'm guessing you're sending out your
your tough guys
and that's not normal for a face-off to
start a match-up
is it well the one thing i'd give peter
laviolette the coach of the washington
capitals a little leeway on that
he doesn't get last change because he's
on the road and usually the line that
you're talking about with dowd hathaway
and hagelin
they play a lot against the other team's
top lines so i don't think they were
sure what exactly mike sullivan was
going to do okay
sorry not myself and i apologize i'm
thinking pittsburgh
uh what david quinn was going to do but
i would tell you this
um david quinn comes with his artillery
they don't have a lot of it obviously
with the rangers and then
everything kind of gets going give us
the back story
on this pier well obviously the tom
wilson situation on monday dan wasn't
something that
uh endeared anybody i think in the
hockey world to what happened
i mean it basically it was tom wilson
getting involved to paddle bouche nevis
and then eventually getting involved
with our timmy panera
panera being a superstar player in the
league and tom wilson basically just
tossing him down to the ice and
could have been very very dangerous
obviously as you know without a helmet
on
if he hits his head instead of a
shoulder dan i think we have a very
large potential problem obviously he hit
his shoulder not nearly as much mayhem
or
injury caused to panerain but that's
really the back story of this whole
thing with tom wilson and the new york
rangers
okay but five thousand dollar fine
no suspension it's not like tom wilson
doesn't have a rap sheet here but
can you can you factor in priors with
someone like tom wilson and should he
have been suspended
well i said last night it begs the
question why wouldn't you have suspended
him for one game and
i think if you had suspended him for
that game last night
you wouldn't have had what we had and
i'll just i won't use my words
dan i'll use the words of brendan smith
who got involved and fought
tom wilson he said at the end of the
game i have no bad blood with anybody on
the washington capitals
i do with tom wilson and so if tom
wilson's not part of the equation
i don't think we have what we had last
night explain the etiquette of fighting
in today's nhl
i don't know if i can things have
changed a lot because of the salary cap
it used to be you could carry
three or four extra players that would
be quote unquote enforcers
i don't think we have the room the
luxury of that anymore not that i call
it a luxury but against the salary cap
it's an issue and now you know you need
to be a player you just can't be a
one-dimensional
asset to a team in terms of policing the
game you've got to be able to play
and if you can't then you're not
valuable i will say this dan i think
it's really important
tom wilson is not a one dimensional
player he's a really good important
power forward for the washington
capitals
he was a major part of a stanley cup
winning team he's not a knuckle driver
he's a legitimate good player
but sometimes he crosses a line and he
did that the other night in new york
okay but how do you get your message
across you know i go back to
when the oilers had dave cemenco
protecting gretzky
how do you how do you enforce without it
being fighting in today's nhl
well i think there's a lot of different
ways you can own the pot the other team
takes penalties trying to defend against
you you run the score up on the power
play
you can play an aggressive four check
game and target some of their defensemen
you can create matchups that you talked
about correctly off the opening face-off
where you put a deck player on against a
star player and you make sure that star
player feels some physical pain
you can do all that stuff um but the
truth of the matter is
i would like to have a player like tom
wilson on my team i wish rick tockett
was still playing in the nhl i had the
privilege of coaching rick we went to
stanley cup with rick and pittsburgh in
1992 and a big reason why we won
the physicality and the dog and
determination of rick talking
they don't make play a lot of players
like that anymore they really don't
five thousand dollars for a guy who
makes whatever five million dollars i
mean that
doesn't seem like that's really
impactful wouldn't wouldn't you take a
five thousand dollar hit
if it meant that you were sending a
message to a team
like wilson did yeah but i don't know
what message he was sending in that
situation
everybody said it was a sprung around
the net yeah it was a harmless scrum and
a power play situation he was out there
actually killing a penalty he knew the
rangers
didn't have any artillery on the ice um
so i don't know what message he's trying
to present it's already a
washington capitals team that's down a
lot of people because of injury and
covert related instances
a team that's a legitimate contender to
win the cup so
i don't know what message he was sending
to the rangers that being said i think
he got himself into trouble now he's
really under scrutiny all the time
every shift he takes in the league he's
under scrutiny now what's the nhl do
if anything today oh they've got a look
at the pavo buchenevic's crosscheck on
anthony mantha
i i don't know what they're going to do
with that that took place in the third
period i mean that wasn't
particularly good so that's something
they're going to have to look at
but all that being said i think they
have to look back and say
did we handle the tom wilson situation
correctly
pierre great to talk to you buddy and uh
have fun tonight probably a little less
drama with the
rangers in bruins right really nice
visiting really dan thanks a lot
that's pierre mcguire nbc sports
continues its coverage of the nhl's push
for the playoffs this week
nbc nbcsn pair of match-ups rangers
bruins tonight at 7 eastern
and then saturday afternoon at 3 eastern
on nbc